a new report this morning explores the
challenges that some Facebook employees
say have plagued the social network for
years
first on CBS this morning we have a look
inside wired magazines March 2018 cover
story about Facebook wire spoke to 51
current and former Facebook employees
about their challenges from battling
fake news to questions about user
privacy one executive said the past year
has made CEO Mark Zuckerberg much more
paranoid about the ways that people
could have used the thing that he built
the company has not yet responded to our
request for comment I'm probably reading
the article right now wired
editor-in-chief in CBS this morning
contributor Nick Thompson co-wrote the
article and is joining us now Nick great
to CEO decision quite the article the
cover shows a beat-up Mark Zuckerberg
over the past two years you've seen this
stock price shoot up their revenues gone
up as well but he's had a lot of other
headaches to deal with talk about the
main ones yeah so the main thesis of the
piece is that this has been the hardest
two years for Zuckerberg he's had
employees who've been upset he's had
massive public criticism Pete had ex
employees saying that Facebook is
tearing apart the fabric of society but
with that image you can also see he
looks confident so one of the final
messages of the piece is that Facebook
actually thinks it's starting to solve
the problems that have created and
what's the big problem it thinks it's
got to have finally got a handle on well
I think what happened at Facebook is
that they didn't understand that the
thing could be misused they really
thought that just the more people who
use Facebook the better the world will
be and then they watched in 2016 when it
didn't have the best effect on American
democracy it hasn't had the greatest
effect on the news industry and it's had
maybe a negative effect on social
movements around the world and so now
it's looking at its algorithms and
looking at how it can be used was that
willful obliviousness because it or did
they really just not know that it could
be abused either by the question of fake
news but also by users who become
addicted to it and so forth it's super
complicated but for one thing their
economic incentives aligned with them
not doing a whole lot about it right
because the more it grows the more money
they make but also a lot of the problems
come about because it is at its core a
democratic platform right the reason why
a fake news publication looks the same
as the New York Times essentially in
your newsfeed isn't from malice it's
because they set it
for everything but with this aim to give
everyone a chance but down the line that
has a huge effect on civil society talk
about some of things you were able to
uncover first of all the controversy
surrounding Facebook's trending topics
yeah so that was very interesting so
what happened is that there was a story
that ran in Gizmodo saying that trending
topics a section in facebook is biased
against Republicans and so Facebook
reacted very strongly to that they said
no we can't have that out there first of
all they said the story is false
then they invited all these Republicans
to come out to Menlo Park to me but what
lots and lots of people told us probably
a dozen people at the company told us is
that after that moment they became
really worried about any action that
could be seen as against Republicans are
against Trump and that is partly why
fake news it's mostly favorite Trump and
the Russian operations which favored
Trump went unnoticed because they had an
incentive not to do anything about it
that was one of the biggest takeaways in
our reporting you also talked about that
that meeting with Republicans and that
they have strategize to as much as they
could right to get them off topic or
some of the tougher questions that they
were asking and you said their internal
investigation into trending topics found
no systemic bias where what did they do
after that investigation where did that
lead them that was one of the fun parts
we had people who helped plan the
meeting they not only wanted to bore the
Republicans who came in they wanted to
get groups of Republicans from different
categories that they would argue with
each other and not be able to get
unified front after that meeting
happened they started to look in and
they started to look into their newsfeed
they started to look at some of the
biggest questions his facebook drive us
apart does it make us more partisan this
newsfeed favor outrage and so ultimately
they began those investigations they
didn't pursue them very hard until after
Trump had won and then they started to
look more closely at what their
algorithms were doing well in the piece
you employees described Mark Zuckerberg
is not sleeping well at night humbled
remorseful and having quote truly been
altered yeah how's he been altered well
I think if you look at his statements
certainly over the past three months he
used to just answer every question by
saying if there's a problem in society
more people will use Facebook and the
problem will go away that was
essentially his answer now he's saying
well you know what we need to make sure
that people use Facebook well but it's
time well spent we need to change your
algorithm so we favor serious
trustworthy publications we need to
local news we need to help civic society
so he's really turning around on all of
these issues all right Nick Thompson try
to read congratulations on all your
reporting more than 50 sources right for
me and Fred vogelstein yeah thank you